herzlich willkommen zu meinem heutigen
video leute ich bin letztens auf youtube
unterwegs gewesen und habe ein video bei
meinen vorschlägen gesehen und zwar
dieses hier konkreter und krankhafter
haben uns das leben gerettet und die
zwei leute im verein auf jeden fall
komplett zerstört hände vom gesicht
zusammengeschlagen der andere tröstet
ihn hand auf der schulter sieht auf
jeden fall nach dem krassen video aus
und ich muss sagen ich persönlich habe
keine erinnerung an irgend einen fall wo
ich diesen jungs das leben gerettet
haben sollte also ich weiß einfach nicht
so wirklich sowas würde ja in erinnerung
bleiben aber ich bin auf jeden fall
gespannt auf die story
guck mal von welchen kanal betreiber das
ist von sexy ist das ja den habe ich
schon das eine oder andere mal in meinen
kommentaren gelesen er schreibt immer
sehr lang und sehr gute kommentare die
nie mit quatsch gefüllt sind krasse
sache also ich bin gespannt ich würde
sagen wir klicken einfach mal rein
die begrüßung von cez diesen klassiker
mittlerweile sie müssen sich vorstellen
ist die youtube begrüßung und juni
bekommen
die letzten arbeiten an dem abend was da
passiert ist ja leute
ok anscheinend ist es schon mal bei der
gamescom letzter abend gamescom hat sich
die story abgespielt ich erinnere mich
sogar dass die beiden wirklich bei uns
waren bei einer gamescom autogrammstunde
bei luca sebastian mir richtig heftiges
passiert
bis aufs messer okay da hat er
anscheinend tief mit simon gehabt also
er hat er hat junge richtig
eingeschrieben vielleicht ist auch siem
und umwelt in der story verwickelt
irgendwie denkbar ist es übernehmen und
zwar wir hatten ein bisschen streit
gehabt mit anderen youtube und das war
genau am ausgang haben zuerst
wahrscheinlichsten ausgang vom
business-bereich gamescom dienstag
runter direkt ja und da hatten wir uns
irgendwie mit überschritten einer der
hat eine maske hat man sofort nicht
erkannt aber das war ein moment wie
andere ich lieber ganz kurzes mundwinkel
hier sie ist der rechte bei youtube
schritten einer der hat eine maske hat
man sofort nicht auch ein youtube oder
zweiten halbjahr 22 hielt über moriske
da haben wir uns bisher mit den
gestritten und sind aneinandergeraten
ein bisschen mit dem diskutiert und ja
man kann ja die weiterziehen eines tages
in eskaliert also wie gesagt wir haben
halt ein paket schild da lassen wir war
ja so ne zum park und da haben wir dann
gechillt wir mit wir uns gedacht wir
haben wir wir dachten jetzt gamescom
letzte park das waren erlebnissen auf
der gamescom haben wir doch jetzt können
wir den abend ausklingen lassen obwohl
man kaum die dann eine art so eine
bierflasche alter und das
unterbewusstsein ist der youtube
assassine hab ich gesagt ja da bin ich
so und da kann denn direkt auf uns zu
mit der flasche hat hat die so kaputt
kaputt gemacht auf jeden fall krasse
story also wie ich verstehe nicht wie
sie lachen können wir haben ihnen das
leben gerettet anscheinend entsteht
jetzt gerade eine lebensbedrohliche
situation zumindest erzählen sie davon
der typ zu haut gerade die bierflasche
und wie die wahrscheinlich angriff mit
der bfr schon sie können so drüber
lachen also dafür auf jeden fall respekt
ja und dann rennt er so auf uns zu mit
der flasche die karten und drei tempel
drauf zu und der hat dann halt wieder
selbst schon gesagt hat die flasche
direkt so war hälfte glaubt stunde hat
ja auch extra aus gekommen wir haben wir
noch die äxte wallaschek natürlich dass
ich gesehen hatte so ist er angekommen
gemacht man kann das schon
außer natürlich wenn herrschte da die
das ist ja spitz diese splitter wenn die
reingehen das uvek als er krasse
geschichte also sie wurden auf der
gamescom einfach angegriffen von von
anderen youtube werden wenn der wagen
was war anders für youtube als zwei
maskierte youtuber auf jeden fall ja das
schon mal als wenn einer mit messer
durch absicht oder so weil haben dadurch
ist die runde viel dreckiger und auch
viel öfter weil das nicht und
feinschnitt ist der kam dann auch der
flasche auch direkt zu tun meinte er wir
werden den attentaten gedroht werde
ihr habt gehört in vier werden euch
jetzt behindert habe und hat der
youtuber scheinbar gesagt krass alter
einfach mit einer kaputten glasflasche
bedrohte die beiden jungstars werde
jetzt eine schlimme erfahrungen dann ja
auf einmal ziemlich und christa der
wollen wir wollte mich dann regen dieser
partie schon unterbrochen war ja heute
top leute das ist eine echte geschichte
falls irgendjemand glaubt das feld ist
nein ist recht weit über mich sagen
greifen und ich bin auch so ganz gut
letzter sekunde ist ausgewichen ich
hatte den job hinter der so wunderbar
ist einfach tauss gesicht vor dem strich
mit der mit der flasche unglaublich
kaputten flasche ausgetreten kaputte
flaschen krasse geschichte auf jeden
fall bis jetzt wurden einfach auf der
gamescom von anderen youtuber
angegriffen mit zuhilfenahme von von
waffen aber was ich mich frage wo sind
denn jetzt luca und ich dabei wir stehen
ja im titel und wir haben ihnen
anscheinend sogar das leben gerettet
also da muss noch richtig abgehen
das wäre natürlich keiner dass ihnen die
kehle aufgeschnitten wird oder
erst mal die kelle aufschneidet märz in
münster sagte bayer trainer ist völlig
so in der youtube szene wo man sich auch
kennen die leute die sind da auch die
helfen sich auch gegenseitig glaube
jetzt können wir ein spiel kommen in der
youtube szene wo man sich auch kennt
hilft man sich gegenseitig vielleicht
kommen wir zu kantig endspiel war die
sind halt in der vier zu zwei
situationen also die anderen sind zu
viert bewaffnen und sie sind zu zweit
bis jetzt gerade so geschafft überhaupt
zu überleben
gute kollegen ist der beweis wie das
konkret aus dem nichts kommende
aufnahmen von der part von einer party
spox wie konnten diese hero akademie
musik oder keine ahnung so nah an ihm
die musik wieder sorgt der post gibt
kein wirksamer kam das aus dem gebüsch
heraus landratsamt dass ich eine gegeben
hat kann ihn einfach ausgenommen wirkt
wer kann man noch dazu
der cdu mann kam kraft da kann dann
direkt ätherisch crafter ich immer noch
dazu erzählt japan kraft kann dann
direkt her gesprintet ich kann direkt
hinterher gespannt ist hinter luca lukac
an den ein anwalt aus gelockt und dann
kann ich direkt hinterher und
wasserdicht gemacht ja und die haben uns
dann geholfen gehalten die haben da ein
bisschen die situation abgekühlt wir
haben genau ich erinnere mich zwar nicht
aber ich kann es mir gut vorstellen dass
wir ja beruhigt euch mal überlegt die
kaputten flasche weg du bleibt liegen
und ihre jungs übertreibt nicht und dann
habe ich die situation zu entspannen
natürlich mit gewalt klärt man nicht
aber die haben dann halt auch ein
bisschen zugeschlagen mit gewalt
lehrreich okay ich zu aber luca und ich
haben dann doch ein bisschen zu schlagen
ok lassen wir mal so stehen wie gesagt
ich erinnere mich an nichts davon krank
oder sogar ich wurde bedroht ich wurde
mit der flasche so über einem spitzel
und dann wollte er mich an gas mit der
flasche und was habe ich dann gesagt das
solowerk mit der erinnerung hat der
krankhaften erst mal so eine richtige
stelle gegeben das haben wir bis zum dom
geöffnet
leute ich will arbeiten für 19
unglaublich also jetzt habe ich einen
griff ich hab mir den waffen haben ihnen
stellen gegeben die man bis zum dom
gehört hat vereinigt sie erzählen diese
im reallife story lachen sich erwiesen
sich gar keine mühe das ist dass
ernsthaft darüber kommt also natürlich
ist es nur erfunden so ihre historie
heute glaube ich zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
jeder gemerkt haben aber erstens warum
und zweitens warum gehen sie sich nicht
einmal mühe das ist vernünftig
rüberkommen ja eigentlich auch so gut
wie vorbei gaben an natürlich bisher die
chrysler dann aus dem kampf aus wir
haben haben uns natürlich bei kompakten
kann kraft getankt aber dann kann ist
eine darauf gestanden einer ist wieder
aufgetaucht fraktion zu machen aber wir
waren zu viert und ihr wollt den konzern
kraft sogar
kontrakte richtig flasche am kopf ziehen
ja aber ich weiß nicht kommt gehabt hat
irgendwie instinktiv bemerkt und dann
gleiten luca ist einfach ausgewichen
also ich habe anscheinend diesen beiden
jungs das leben gerettet ist unglaublich
dann kam kann kraft kraft kraft
wir nahmen wir räuberleiter gemacht also
ich hoffe sie haben sie ja ja genau das
ist ja wirklich der hand auch so ich
weil ich fand es auch jetzt nicht so
aufgeregt und da habe ich ja den auf
jeder hat so ein kick gegeben an dem
eine gesundheitsreform an hilfe sind das
ist dass wir ein video also entscheiden
die eine räuberleiter gegeben damit ich
hoch geschoben hat den doppelklick
gegeben und dann noch ein superman punch
wald aber auch zwei maskierte leute um
die wagen heraus so ok kraft anscheinend
kommen jetzt dazu wer die maskierten
sind wir sind die beiden youtuber die
der angriff geleitet haben gegen die
beiden das interessiert mich jetzt
wirklich weil ist sieht man unter einer
von dem wir haben ja am anfang gesehen
die auf einen streit auf jeden fall top
habt ihr und ich und krankhafter und
uniqa wollten halt wissen weg auf dem
maskierten sinn mehr ich einen so
genommen tragkraft geld eingenommen so
also umkamen und bei krankhafter wollte
sogar so oben und ich weiß gar nicht wer
das gemacht erzählt könnten den
glücklichsten waren nicht aber ein hoch
bei mir war der so oben
es ist also unterschätzt den ich der tür
auf kraft wirklich kraft kontakt ist
auch gratis gehört das will ich noch mal
anhören also unterschätzt den ich derart
ich meine freunde in krass unterschätzt
mich niemals und deshalb wenn ich er
wäre hätte ich jetzt auch in dieser
stelle abonniert spätestens dann haben
und ich weiß es nicht hören wollten
juli als wenn einer von den angreifern
war julien der julien bei der der
erfolgreiche youtuber 2017 war der hat
die alle dürfen einer weinbar juni wo
mein körper keine studien werden was
hast du gegen uns und und ja und da
andere typ das war christina knuspert
genuss
überhaupt julian berg und knuspern die
beiden jungs umbringen wollen und wir
haben ihnen das leben gerettet haben
die firma hat knapp wie hast du dafür
vom trip über drauf aber bei dem man das
am schwersten zu trinken kind und die
lacher auf
sobald wir das war echt lustig dann im
moment war auch so glücklich und noch
parat hier aber anhalten
das könnt ihr durch noch bitte an die
war wirklich alle geschafft auch gar
antrag song den wir sind was ist das was
ist das für ein format und er findet
einfach falsche release net hed team auf
youtube also ich finde jetzt verlust ich
habe dem sowie auch unterhaltsam aber
was ist das paar kraft die waren echt
tag geschockten moment ich habe jetzt
gerade gesagt es ist fake aber was wäre
wenn wir einfach durch den schock unsere
erinnerung verloren haben weil lukas ich
waren ja so stark geschockt und das hat
sich alles so zugetragen aber ja
scheinbar leute hat sich die story
erledigt es geht noch fast 3 minuten das
video ich will gar nicht wissen dass
heute erzählt habe ich verlinke euch das
original natürlich auch nochmal falls
ihr da irgendwie ein interesse ab das
herauszufinden aber ja anscheinend ist
das die story gewesen wie luca und ich
jemanden das leben gerettet haben zwei
leuten sogar das leben gerettet haben ja
und ich hoffe mal dass wie hat euch
irgendwie gefallen es war jetzt eine
krasse story wir haben einfach diesen
beiden typen das leben gerettet luca und
ich dafür könnte jetzt wirklich mal
leichter lassen weil wie oft hört ja so
eine geschichte größe gehen raus an die
beiden auf jeden fall machte diesen
bomben content und dann bis zum nächsten
mal wir sind morgen wieder bis dahin und
ciao